[Musica]
Grazie questo è il secondo di silenzio
prima che tutte queste meraviglie hanno
inizio questo è il secondo di silenzio
che ha portato la mia vita a dire sì da
subito da quando ero bambina Perché di
fatto io la meraviglia l'ho sempre
cercata un po' dappertutto ho cominciato
facendo l'attrice letteralmente ho
proprio fatto una carriera di
professionista Però in ogni cosa che io
facevo che poi è diventata fare
documentari di viaggi o occuparsi di
spettacoli a vero livello Io cercavo
sempre un qualcosa che meraviglie me per
prima mi sono interrogata su quello che
avevo voglia di condividere questa
platea perché quello che per me è molto
importante sia che sia un grande Show
che sia una testimonianza come quella di
oggi è la relazione con il pubblico
credo che ci sia una relazione di cause
ed effetto tra quello che io racconto e
il modo in cui voi lo percepite questo
mi porterà a raccontarvi quattro storie
quattro storie che sono quattro storie
tra tante di quelle che vedete alle mie
spalle che sono la maggior parte degli
spettacoli che ho avuto l'onore di
guidare o ho avuto l'onore di seguire
durante tutto il mio
percorso le quattro storie in realtà
cominciano da una piccola rivelazione
perché io realmente non avevo proprio le
idee chiare di quello che volevo fare
ero un'attrice Sì abbastanza bravina
Però in realtà ad un certo punto questo
palco mi stava stretto avevo l'esigenza
di guardare le cose da un altro punto di
vista e ho utilizzato la creatività
questo dono meraviglioso che molti di
noi hanno questo dono che non si sa bene
Da dove risieda di cui noi siamo canali
incredibili e che abbiamo la fortuna di
Met metter in scena a un certo punto c'è
stata una rivelazione era il 2004 e in
televisione Assisto questo spettacolo
incredibile delle Olimpiadi di Atene
Questo stadio meraviglioso pieno d'acqua
con questa acqua a filo una piccola
barchetta la potenza gigantesca di
queste immagini in bianco di questo
grande creatore che era Dimitri papai
joanno io rimango ad occhi aperti
l'apertura degli occhi infatti nel
Buddismo è la prima rivelazione il
momento in cui GL appare Chiara Quella
che potenzialmente potrebbe essere la
tua prova e così finalmente arriva un
altro momento molto importante
lentamente mi accorgevo che c'era un
avvicinamento a questo mondo era il 2006
di nuovo davanti alla televisione
spettatrice mi trovo di fronte a questa
piccola bambina che canta l'inno
d'Italia attraversando Questo stadio
prima di lei Carla Bruni con una
bandiera dell'Italia piegata in quattro
parti una rivoluzione Perché la bandiera
si porta aperta regola del protocollo
erano le Olimpiadi Invernali di Torino
create da Marco balici insieme ad altri
creatori incredibili Ecco in quel
momento Io esprimo un desiderio ad occhi
aperti Io nella vita voglio fare questo
lavoro ma non sapevo esattamente come
potevo arrivarci lo giuro non avevo
proprio la la benché minima idea non c'è
un modo per
prepararsi nel 2009 accade un qualcosa
di straordinario mi viene prop
di fare una cerimonia come producer Ma
io letteralmente volevo proprio
approcciarmi a quel mondo e quindi
accetto di farla e letteralmente mi
trovo a pascolare le pecore Forse vi
ricete che nel 2009 in Abruzzo ci fu
questo terremoto tremendo e noi ci
trovavamo a Pescara a fare la cerimonia
dei giochi del
Mediterraneo lo stadio era diventato un
campo base i volontari le persone senza
più casa le persone che avevano perso
amici parenti le persone erano nella
disperazione e noi facevamo uno
spettacolo la cosa più inutile al mondo
in realtà però in quella cerimonia io ho
capito una cosa molto importante la
grande capacità che il creativo deve
avere di empatizzare con il sociale
perché il sociale È disturbato è
alterato il sociale vibra a temperature
diverse lo abbiamo sentito il sociale ha
bisogno attraverso lo spettacolo di
rassicurazioni o di
restituzioni quel giorno durante quella
cerimonia c'era Ramazzotti che stava
cantando questa canzone per l'Abruzzo
c'eran la squadra di
rugby del abruzzese c'erano gli
sbandieratori e in cuffia si sente
vogliamo scendere vogliamo scendere
erano tutti i volontari ed erano tutte
le persone che avevano preso parte a
quella cerimonia che volevano fare
Un'invasione di campo che non si può
fare perché niente di quello che non
provi tu puoi riuscire a fare e invece
in quell'occasione viene detto sì Go e
in un attimo noi ci ritrovamo in lacrime
perché ci ritrovamo di fronte a questo
stadio pieno di persone che erano tutte
unite da questo grande abbraccio verso
l'Abruzzo io non riesco a descrivervi la
grande emozione quello che posso dirvi
però è che in quelle occasione ho
imparato quanto le cerimonie quanto
questi grandi Show abbiano questa
capacità di leggere il presente di
ribadire quelli che sono dei valori
universali l'umanità la persona al
centro del tutto non solo una macchina
scenica è vero noi fotografiamo il
momento storico lo restituiamo lo
leggiamo in trasversale ci mettiamo
effetti speciali ma di fatto sempre
nella relazione con il pubblico Vogliamo
entrare e questa è stata la cerimonia di
chiusura di di di
Pescara la terza storia che voglio
raccontarvi mi sta molto cuore perché in
realtà è stata una prova importante per
me qui siamo già nel
2014 e io ho dimenticato di dire che
stavo già lavorando con i creatori della
prima cerimonia che avevo visto nella
mia vita quindi in qualche modo il mio
desiderio si stava avverando io ci stavo
credendo quella cosa accadeva
inclusività e creatività era il 2014
sono le cerimonie olimpiche di soci
Russia grandi contenuti un grande senso
dello stato un grande senso del dell'ego
un grande una grande potenza della
cultura russa E noi arriviamo alla fine
di tutto il percorso con una cerimonia
paralimpica il movimento paralimpico nel
mondo del dello sport è un movimento che
ha fatto straordinarie rivoluzioni in
quell'occasione attraverso un Concept
non inventato da me ma inventato da un
gruppo di creativi
internazionali ci troviamo a mettere
l'apostrofo e quell' apostrofo ha
generato un movimento in realtà tutto
partiva dal fatto che volevamo
raccontare come qualcosa che sembra
impossibile improvvisamente può
diventare possibile ed eravamo lì un po'
a cellar di come poter mettere in scena
questo quando ad un certo punto doug
Jack uno dei più grandi coreografi di
massa al mondo perché poi le cerimonie
si fanno con le masse si fanno con le
persone si fanno si fanno con il cuore
delle persone dice vabbè ma spostiamo
l'apostrofo e questa è la scena che
abbiamo realizzato incontrando un
personaggio incredibile che si chiamava
alexei chuac e che aveva perso le sue
gambe a causa di un incidente
bellico
[Musica]
questa piccolo gesto in realtà fu un
grande gesto per tutto il movimento
paralimpico perché in realtà da questo
piccolo gesto il comitato poi
paralimpico decise di inventare un
premio Quindi in realtà la traslazione
tra quella che è un'idea creativa e
quella che poi diventa un movimento
il vero altro valore delle cerimonie
sono i volontari quindi la massa per
quanto riguarda tutte le coreografie di
masse Ma chi è Poi questa massa di
persone che vediamo muoversi come tanti
puntini sono i volontari sono il cuore
di ogni iniziativa come il cuore del Ted
come il cuore delle
cerimonie e siete tutti voi persone
meravigliose dotate di un cuore
incredibile che dedicano og minuto della
loro vita per questa narrazione
collettiva perché è questo di cui si
parla loro stanno scegliendo noi noi che
siamo sul palco stanno scegliendo voi
per raccontare anche la loro personalità
tra quei volontari arrivo alla mia altra
storia Io incontro una bambina Questa
bambina si chiama bulan bulan in
indonesiano vuol dire
Luna Queste erano le cerimonie ie
asiatiche ora quando io faccio questi
lavori prendo e mi trasferisco
completamente in un altro luogo imparo
un po' la lingua imparo gli usi i
costumi rimango me stessa ma cerco di
non giudicare cerco di farmi strumento
cerco di essere uno specchio o un imbuto
poco importa stavo faccendo questa
cerimonia il capo del Comitato Olimpico
mi dice non sono contento voglio di più
tra questi volontari quindi io incontro
bulan bulan è una bambina che fa un
concorso di Trivial a scuola vince
questo concorso di Trivial perché era
stato un concorso indetto dal Presidente
della Repubblica indonesiana e bouan
vince una bicicletta bouan scrive una
lettera al presidente Caro Presidente io
la ringrazio molto che lei mi ha
regalato questa bicicletta Però le
vorrei dire se possiamo permutare la
bicicletta con una sedia a rotelle
poiché Io ho una grave invalidità il
presidente ovviamente regala a bulan Rot
ma bulan diventa protagonista di un
gesto ancora più incredibile perché
scopriamo Tra le tante cose che bulan
tirava anche con l'arco e il presidente
tirava anche con l'arco insieme tra il
pregiudizio la difficoltà della politica
un perché poi mi trovo sempre a lavorare
con questi stati particolari ma in
realtà io non ho lenti non ho
pregiudizio il mio sguardo e per fortuna
arrivo Grazie al grande contributo delle
persone che incontro a realizzare questo
tipo di azioni in
[Musica]
scena
rimanga tra noi ma il presidente in
realtà non era riuscito a centrare con
la freccia l'obiettivo bulan Sì ma non
glielo
dite la quarta è un altro dono
dell'universo Io non lo so da dove
arrivino le idee ma ad un certo punto se
non arrivano le idee arrivano le persone
se non arriva l'esperienza arriva
l'istinto qualcosa accade e questa è la
quarta storia il femminile non ha genere
e ve lo spiego perché non ha genere
perché mi trovo in un altro paese al
mondo l'Arabia Saudita No io non ci
voglio andare in Arabia Saudita io in un
posto dove alle do e mi fermo e dico Ma
io come faccio a lavorare a questo
progetto che cosa abbiamo in comune
perché sulle diversità siamo tutti
d'accordo ma che cosa abbiamo in comune
e scopro che in realtà c'è una cosa
molto potente che abbiamo in comune che
è la terra che sono i segni della terra
che sono anche gli stessi segni che
abbiamo sulle nostre mani sul palmo
della nostra mano e così nasce Leila de
Land of immagination una specie di Alice
Alice oltre lo specchio un'alice nel
paese delle meraviglie che è una bambina
un personaggio completamente di
immaginazione ma dopodiché facciamo
casting tra circa una trentina di
bambine saudite e questo è uno
spettacolo che è ispirato al
Corano letto una specie di piccola
versione molto molto compatta del Corano
per arrivare a rendermi conto che in
realtà c'è tutto il mito della creazione
là dentro c'è l'acqua le suure del
Corano sono ispirate all'acqua sono
ispirate alla creazione pura sono
ispirate anche alla scoperta e per la
prima volta riusciamo a mettere in scena
una danzatrice molto giovane che si
presta a fare una scena tutta dedicata
alla poesia e all'immaginazione
Leila Land the Land of immagination è
stato questo grande regalo che poi in
realtà ho ricevuto perché Leila è stato
uno spettacolo anche questo incredibile
pieno di significati e più che altro uno
spettacolo che ha lasciato una Legacy
importante perché è uno spettacolo
diretto da una donna prodotto da delle
donne realizzato da altrettante donne
uno spettacolo che va oltre ogni tipo di
forma pensiero e anche immaginazione
a questo punto il tema è che cosa hanno
in comune tutte queste storie Beh il
fatto che come dicevo la creatività è
una scelta è una visione improvvisa è
una cosa che non ti aspetti e che poi
alla fine bisogna prendersela un po' di
responsabilità perché nella regola del
grande del piccolo c'è sempre qualcosa
di buono tu parla di una cosa piccolo
fallo sposta l'accento spostala metti un
punto non importa il genere ma tu fallo
prendilo con coraggio
e poi le idee dove sono queste idee
stanno nel cuore stanno nella mente c'è
una piccola fatina qua sulla spalla
sinistra che ti dice Fai così fai così
fai così non lo so ma le idee in teoria
le idee in pratica e quelle che non ti
aspetti sono quelle che voglio
raccontarvi adesso Questa è un'idea nata
durante il lockdown non è mai nata
questa cerimonia non c'è mai stata ma la
voglio testimoniare qui perché questo
Concept creativo è un Concept che poi Ha
illuminato il Concept delle dei del
della World Cup che è l'ultimo grande
evento che ho fatto di cui ho curato la
direzione artistica prodotto da balic
Wonder studio Questo era un Concept
molto importante che era Will Delight Fi
the distance la storia d'amore tra due
luci Ecco in un momento così complesso
come il lockdown in un momento di grande
distanza cercavo un modo per raccontare
come potevamo essere vicini gli uni agli
altri la storia d'amore tra due luci mi
sembrava un modo interessante per
raccontare la luce interiore Ma questo
spettacolo non ha mai visto la luce ma
lo volevo condividere con
voi questo signore Qui si chiama laib e
probabilmente l'avrete visto era la
mascot De del dei della World Cup e mi
sono trovata a trovare un modo per
metterlo in scena e quindi ho detto
oddio come si fa far apparire questo
grande pupazzone invertebrato che
ricorda un fazzoletto pausa per pranzo
le idee praticamente scariche un calo un
calo di zuccheri e improvvisamente dico
Certo così come un fazzoletto di carta e
così abbiamo fatto questo disegnino e
dopodiché abbiamo chiamato Insomma
grandi progettisti perché lavorando a
livello internazionale abbiamo il
privilegio di poter collaborare con
altri colleghi e mente brillante che
vengono da tutto il mondo che fanno
Onore alle grandi menti brillanti che ci
sono in Italia questi sono alcuni
disegni tecnici della progettazione di
laib questo è il laib tridimensionale
Questa è la prima volta che vedo laib e
questo è quello che ha visto tutto il
mondo l'apparizione di laib in realtà è
stato una meraviglia perché laib apparì
con un cartone animato e poi
improvvisamente quando meno te lo
aspetti lui appare come il fazzoletto di
carta di quando stavamo facendo la
nostra pausa a pranzo e quello che si
sente sotto il clamore del pubblico
l'applauso del
pubblico è il motivo per cui faccio
questo lavoro ed è l'ultima storia con
cui poi vi lascio è quella che non ti
aspetti ossia l'incontro meraviglioso
con Morgan Freeman e ganim che sono
stati due protagonisti della della World
Cup
e per per questa World Cup abbiamo fatto
delle cose gigantesche abbiamo fatto uno
spettacolo in acqua la cerimonia di
apertura la cerimonia di chiusura appeso
uno squalo Insomma abbiamo regalato
veramente creato grandi immagini potenti
e poi abbiamo fatto la cerimonia
d'apertura
molti non sanno Forse perché abbiamo
messo seduto e terra Morgan Freeman e
ganim il motivo in realtà c'è loro
dovevano finire su quei due ponti Questo
era quello che volevano non loro ma
quello che volevamo noi pensavamo che
fosse questa l'immagine importante ma in
realtà in prova poi accade qualcosa di
completamente di
che sentiamo un'emozione molto grande
nel vederli in realtà seduti in terra
ancora una volta una piccola cosa che
racconta semplicemente un dialogo tra
due esseri
[Musica]
umani su quei ponti loro non ci sono
finiti in realtà si sono connessi solo
col potere della loro parola
e questo potere della parola è il potere
della personalità creativa non so se
sono riuscita a
raccontare quello che provo quello che
sento quello che sono non solo io tanti
altri che come me fanno questo lavoro
con cui condivido questa mente creativa
questa voglia di di di di di di dar
retta all'istinto perché alla fine la
creatività altro non è che è un fuoco
sacro a cui tutti che tutti quanti
dobbiamo un pochino ascoltare Grazie
[Applauso]
infinite